So what impact
will this
have actually on the battlefield?
Well, let's start
with the tanks themselves.
This is the German
Shepherd, very similar to the Abrams.
Highly capable,
certainly more capable
than the Russian made T-72,
which the Ukrainians have tended
to rely on. But here's a key point.
Also, an offensive weapon
with Ukrainians,
as you heard from the defense minister.
They're hoping that
this will help them retake territory
that Russia has occupied
since the start of this invasion.
So let's look at the numbers, though.
Here are the tanks by country so far,
any disunity clearly has dissolved.
You've got America.
You're Germany,
the U.K., also Poland, sending tanks in.
But look at these numbers here.
That total from these
three countries is 59 tanks with others,
you get closer to 100.
How does that fit into
the broader picture in Ukraine?
We don't know how many tanks exactly
Russia and Ukraine are using.
We just don't trust their numbers.
We do know
or have a good sense
of how many been lost
since the start of the war.
These are numbers
compiled by Oryx,
and they based this on open source,
but only what they can confirm
via video seeing tanks destroyed.
And so far,
more than 600 Russian tanks,
close to 500 Ukrainian tanks.
That's more than 2000 tanks lost.
Gives you a sense
of how many are on the battlefield there.
And then you compare
that 59,
perhaps it gets up to 100 over the next
several months.
Even the president
granted there
it's going to take time
to get them in there.
The math doesn't add up in terms
of leveling
the playing field between what
Russia has, what Ukraine has.
And here's one more point
I would make when I speak to U.S.
military officials.
There is a school of thought among U.S.
officials
that Ukraine
is not
ideally equipped for a big tank battle.
It's much better
equipped for smaller, more mobile units.
That's where they had all the success
destroying Russian
tanks in the early stages
of the war around Kiev.
That's why this weapon system
with which the U.S.
has also sent
in the Bradley
Fighting Vehicle,
which, by the way, has anti-tank
capabilities with the TOW missile
mounted here
just on the left side of its turret
there are many in the U.S.
that believe
that's the better path for Ukraine.
Smaller,
lighter, more mobile,
requiring less support
than trying to beat the Russians.
A tank warfare in the East
Those
TOW anti-tank missiles
are really, really important.
Jim Sciutto, stay with us.
I want to get some analysis
right now as well
from CNN's Kate Bolduan.
And retired U.S.
Army General Wesley Clark.
He's a CNN military analyst.
General Clark, how critical is this move?
Alisyn, both Leppard and Abrams
battle tanks to Ukraine.
And is the U.S.
doing everything possible
to address the potential complications
associated with the Abrams tanks?
Well, I think all these tanks
being provided is really,
really essential
because even as late as last summer,
six months ago,
Ukrainians were running out
of main gun ammunition
for their T-72 tanks.
And there's a worldwide shortage,
just 125 millimeter ammunition.
So they needed
and they've been asking for our tanks
for months with tanks.
Still aren't there, of course.
And as Jim Sciutto pointed out,
they're going
what's going to be
there is a small number compared to what
their need is.
So, yes, the tanks are important.
They're more important
as a symbol of U.S.
and European commitment.
But in the defense,
you've got to have some armor
for local reserves.
So we are here to
talk about the iron fist
and taking back the territory.
That's good.
What we're also
facing the prospect
of a major Russian offensive.
And if that Russian offensive comes,
the tanks,
even these small numbers of tank
could be very significant.
If they get to the right spot
to cut off the penetration,
you know, that's a good point.
You know,
Katie Bowe,
you're doing a lot of reporting
on this as well.
What are you hearing?
What does this U.S.
decision say
about their view of the timeline
of how long this war
could actually drag on?
Wolf, what I think is really telling
is the way that Biden administration
officials are framing the decision
to send the Abrams.
They're framing it
as a long term commitment
to Ukraine's capabilities,
which really backs up
what I think we've been hearing from U.S.
intelligence and military officials
for a while now,
which is that they don't see this war
winding down anytime soon.
Ukraine obviously
is not planning on stopping fighting.
And I spoke to a senior
Western intelligence official last week
who said, look,
all the indications that we have is
that Putin is convinced,
that is still convinced
that he can defeat
Ukraine militarily on the battlefield.
So at this point, U.S.
officials don't believe
that there is a negotiated settlement
in the cards any time soon.
They also don't believe that
there is a decisive
military resolution coming
anytime soon,
which is exactly what you heard
from chairman of the Joint Chiefs
General Mark Milley last week,
telling reporters
that he believed
it would be incredibly difficult
for Ukraine to eject Russia
from all of its territory
within the next year.
So, Wolf,
that's the context in which U.S.
officials are making this decision
on the Abrams a long, hard slog.
Jim, in that context, what specifically
will Ukraine try to accomplish
in the short run,
in the short term,
in the coming months, let's say,
with the German
Shepherd battle tanks
and eventually the U.S.
Abrams tanks arriving,
their hope is to take back territory.
That's their intention.
They don't want to rest
on their laurels, laurels.
They don't want to sue for peace
and grant territory
in exchange for peace.
You heard from
the defense minister there.
He hopes that these tanks will be part
of an offensive that can punch through
Russian lines, in effect.
And we should not
diminish Ukraine's ability to do
counter offensives.
They had enormous success
just a few months ago around hockey.
Surprising everybody really
with the speed of their advance there.
But the fact is,
the battlefield in the east
is different now.
It's more dug in its flatlands.
There are trenches.
There are artillery pieces.
There are tank divisions there.
And that's one reason
we've seen the casualty count,
the daily casualty count.
They're so horrific.
So those are Ukrainian hopes.
They hope that
this will make a different difference.
But as Katie Bowe said
from the U.S., perspective,
they don't expect this
to be winding down anytime soon.
The U.S.
expects us to be a grinding
continuation of months and months of war.
Yeah, that's that's what they expect.
General Clark, what does this say
that the Western allies
finally took this step today,
despite all of Russia's
very public and private threats
John, you know, this is
the policy
is to slowly
ramp up the assistance to Ukraine.
And at every step,
yes, Moscow is going to object,
but not to do it
in such an abrupt way
that it triggers an escalation,
a real escalation to nuclear joke.
This is the administration's strategy
to keep the war going,
lead Russia,
support Ukraine, hope
that Ukraine can win, but don't do enough
to totally turn it upside down suddenly
so Putin can knee
jerk wise use nuclear weapons.
And that's that's
the goal of the administration.
This is perfectly and part of it.
Dramatic developments, indeed.
Guys, thank you very, very much.